what's up guys my name is Q and I love
makeup so today I'm gonna be eating
McDonald's from the US and Thailand and
I'll see which one's better I'm gonna
try the signature sandwiches some
dessert and of course the one Melanie
big yep I'm gonna start with the
signature sandwiches let's dive in right
now okay I mean overall look is good but
let's try it look good mushroom man very
good if there was nothing else available
I would get this I've made it to
Thailand there we go let's start with
the basic Angus burger looks pretty
standard can't really complain this is a
really good like I've had to compare
it's like a double cheeseburger back
home like it gave me that type of
satisfaction nice burger look there's
more of mushroom but okay this is a
double smokehouse burger signature baby
pretty much face the same as last one
just brought me this is the double Angus
beef burger already a lot heavier I like
pretty much like the same setup some Big
Mac sauce we got some lettuce on there
got a nice glob of Big Mac sauce here
the Big Mac sauce here the little
sweeter is so good this is the bacon
smokehouse crispy chicken everything on
this looks crispy I mean like crispy
onions crispy chicken crispy bacon mmm
this is the one right here whoa whoa
wait whoa whoa what is that all around
like this is definitely the best
signature sandwich they have for sure
the super double Angus burger it's heavy
I feel like I'm lifting what six-pack
coming soon baby huge piece of bacon on
there look at that
hopefully the bacon is crunchy and
crispy cuz that might put Tyler over the
top
we very tasty actually
like it really changed the sandwich 100%
think I'm getting better brain since I
haven't brain freeze buffer like maybe
too many barriers it's perfect Oh
tastes just like spray a classic the Big
Mac this is like the equivalent of a
krabby patty but in real life does go on
this side winners for sure this is the
double Big Mac this baby has four
patties Matt cheese Matt lettuce is
about to go down little one this is what
you call creativity as martyrs moving on
to the two-piece we make fried chicken
this is impressive
this is some for real fried chicken to
be honest this by itself could be a
reason that Thailand wins this battle I
don't think there's anything on the
American menu that can compare to some
good fried chicken all right
apple pie in my opinion I mean as far as
fast food dessert goes you really can't
beat it this time I'm gonna say this is
the best thing I had so far it's
bringing me back not to like my
grandma's cooking or something but just
bring me back to McDonald exactly where
I would have you I'm actually pretty
excited for this I'm a big pineapple van
hmm this is pretty good I can't complain
this McFlurry was made perfectly it's
gonna be hard to beat something so
simple yet so
you have really time McDonald's for the
desserts
hands down 100% going with America on
those McDonald's from us is what I've
always had everything was pretty solid
that Fried Chicken I feel like it got to
put the timing down over the top guess
I'll give them a drum
[Music]
[Music]